we welcome you back to the Drew
Barrymore show my name is Gail King and
you may know our next guest
from 15 and getting straight
Wayne's World 2 or how about this her
Cameo and wax works too
[Applause]
Drew Barrymore
[Applause]
so what is happening in that clip we
just watched you were the blonde in the
middle so this was wax works too and the
director called me and said can you show
up at this mall at midnight we're going
to shoot a scene and we need two
actresses uh in you know in a bed but
we're just shooting it in the middle of
a mall and you even know who the other
actress is beside you do you remember
she's not an actress she was my friend
Hadrian I was like I'm with my
girlfriend Hadrian like and he's like
bring her too he said bring her too and
that's how we ended up in a scene in wax
works too that's funny that's funny so
that's the back story
is always asking guests about behind the
scenes moments from their projects So
today we're turning the tables on you
and asking about you I can't believe it
it's time for behind the scenes do you
feel like playing yes I do
you
I think this is hilarious first up Amy
Fisher that was such a huge story I was
very uncomfortable
um it was like one of my first roles
that was sexy you know she was the Long
Island Lolita I was trying to change my
own image from being like a kid you know
actress and I thought oh well go sexy
that'll be a interesting turn of events
but I wasn't comfortable doing it
um and then I got really comfortable
doing it for many years so this film
sort of broke me next doppelganger they
kept sending me home early which never
happens on movie sets so that they could
film stuff that they wouldn't tell me
was happening in the movie but
apparently I keep turning into some
alien but I wasn't there when they shot
those scenes because I don't know they
didn't want to tell me that so I still
have never seen the full movie well
there's time yeah oh God there's time
it's okay so bad bad girls okay this was
important for me
this was huge this was the first time I
got hired back for a studio film because
all I was doing were B movies
and
um I had just had a B-movie hit called
Poison Ivy I remember that yes
thank you let's go to Wedding Singer I
Love Wedding Singer because if you and
Adam Sandler
I love you and Adam Sandler well I
showed up to Adam and I said I'm
convinced you and I are supposed to do a
movie together and I have a production
company that I'm starting flower films
you have Happy Madison and I'd like to
join forces what if we put our
production companies together and
created something Wedding Singer was
born and The Wedding Singer the haircut
I love the haircut you love the haircut
okay
Charlie's Angels
yes
yes yes yes yes
women always have to be so serious and
brooding an action movie that was quite
the trio and it reminds me your very
first show you did you did a reunion
with that's what I remember I've never
seen a the technology that you did it
was just so nice to see the three of you
so Bravo to you gray Gardens
I am oh wow the director didn't want me
um Michael soucy
um and they kept saying we want an
actress who has won awards for this film
so did you convince him to put you so I
showed up and I said I just want you to
hear my case
and I sat down and I brought a binder
this big and every page was highlighted
and annotated and it was about her life
and there were probably over a thousand
pages in there and I said I will work
night and day I will get lost in this
but I know you want someone who's won
awards how do you think those people get
that chance wow yes
so weird
that's why who I always say when someone
says no no backwards is on so you say
game on and that's what you did and
finally
I I chose E.T for me I chose E.T I love
E.T
is still playing
we actually found a clip of you really
doing your own performance of E.T oh my
God roll tape please
what do you think of the job she did
you have mixed feelings about it didn't
you think you did a real good job that's
medium
one down I wanna piss medium
so I'm still not critical that movie
taught me that if you are not born into
a strong family unit that you can find
it along the way yes yes yes
and it changed my life forever you can
always go and Forge and find and form
families and I think all of these
experiences have been about wanting to
hold on to that and be a part of keeping
that going that's been my real life
Source
May that continue would you mind taking
us to break
I would love to Gail when we come back
we're going to give you a taste of the
latest trues News podcast episode
because we get to get a lot spicier
there you know it's not daytime Gail we
get to go to some more less PG a little
more not exactly are but somewhere I'm
being tween
[Music]